[Música]
hoy el congreso de eeuu de ver a
reinstalarse para votar sobre el
presupuesto para la infraestructura la
noche del jueves el presidente de byd en
firmó la ley presupuestaria que evitó lo
que parecía ser un inminente cierre de
gobierno queda aún por definirse el
techo de la deuda en ese país en
venezuela hoy entra en vigor una tercera
reconversión monetaria según el gobierno
para facilitar el manejo del dinero en
efectivo los billetes circularán con
seis ceros menos y aunque los expertos
aseguran que esto no va a frenar la
inflación los venezolanos volverán a
tener bolívares en efectivo en sus manos
después de una larga escasez de papel
moneda
y miles de jóvenes de todo el mundo se
toman las calles para reclamar que se
actúen contra el cambio climático hoy
viernes 24 de septiembre después de un
año y medio de restricciones por la
pandemia del movimiento ecologista
freites for filter retomó su actividad
en 1500 ciudades de todo el planeta
muy buen día gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france 24 sur hablan como
siempre un gusto acompañarlos comenzamos
el presidente de eeuu o you buy dan
firmó una ley de presupuesto que
mantiene el financiamiento del gobierno
federal hasta el 3 de diciembre poco
después que el senado y la cámara de
representantes lo aprobaran evitando a
última hora un cierre del gobierno que
había dejado temporalmente a miles de
empleados federales es sin empleo se
espera que hoy el congreso vote el
presupuesto para la infraestructura de
informes entre amaia
un primer gran triunfo para los
demócratas en eeuu el presidente joe
biden y la presidenta de la cámara de
representantes firmaron este jueves la
resolución aprobada por el congreso para
el presupuesto fiscal que financiará al
gobierno hasta el próximo 3 de diciembre
bailén firmó a puerta cerrada horas
antes de alcanzar el plazo de la
medianoche del jueves tiempo en que el
año presupuestario concluía en un
comunicado el mandatario dijo hay mucho
más por hacer pero la aprobación de este
proyecto de ley nos recuerda que el
trabajo bipartidista es posible y nos da
tiempo para aprobar fondos a más largo
plazo para mantener a nuestro gobierno
funcionando y cumpliendo para el pueblo
estadounidense
pero aún quedan algunos pendientes sobre
la mesa falta aprobar el aumento del
techo de la deuda y así evitar que eeuu
incurra en una suspensión de pagos de la
deuda nacional
es imperativo que el congreso aborde el
límite de la deuda de lo contrario
nuestra estimación actual es que el
tesoro probablemente agotará sus medidas
extraordinarias para el 18 de octubre en
ese momento el tesoro se quedará con
recursos muy limitados que se agotarán
rápidamente
eeuu dejaría de pagar por primera vez en
la historia
de llegar a suceder la secretaria del
tesoro aseguró que el crédito del país
se vería afectado y enfrentarían
posiblemente una crisis financiera y una
recesión otra batalla pendiente es el
proyecto de un billón de dólares
destinado a reconstruir la
infraestructura del país y cuya votación
fue pospuesta en la cámara de
representantes para este viernes a
partir de hoy primero de octubre
venezuela tiene un nuevo cono monetario
se trata de la tercera reconversión
monetaria en 13 años la hiperinflación
la dificultad de las transacciones
administrativas y bancarias en el país
empujaron al gobierno de nicolás maduro
a tomar la medida de quitarse seis ceros
al bolívar
teórico rubio comerciante informal se
muestra escéptico ante la tercera
reconversión monetaria que entra en
vigor en venezuela a partir del primero
de octubre cree que la medida no
solucionará el problema de fondo una
inflación que supera el mil 700 por
ciento y que han generado la escasez de
billetes en la última década cuando
supuestamente eso no va a solucionar
nada digamos
con la parte económica dios quiera que
suben es para movilizar y administrar
todos supuestamente lo están haciendo lo
que escuche se lo están haciendo para la
broma de contabilidad inglesa la parte
bancaria
la parte económica digamos de negocios
que yo puedan trabajar el nuevo cono
monetario es decir el nuevo circulante
tendrá seis ceros menos y se llamará
bolívar digital los analistas sostienen
que la decisión es sólo un paño de agua
caliente
entonces la reconversión si es una nueva
una solución es un alivio pero la
verdadera el verdadero problema es
acabar con la inflación volver a sacar
las monedas adaptar los sistemas esos
son costos que se reflejan en última
instancia también en la inflación y en
la economía en general
sin embargo algunos venezolanos esperan
resultados positivos
espero que sea para bien
económico del trabajo del 7 es un pueblo
de mejor manera
que ayuden con el poder adquisitivo
risas un señor que yo lo creo
innecesario
con el bautizado bolívar digital el
gobierno también quiere impulsar aún más
las transacciones virtuales mecanismo
que se aceleró por la falta del papel
moneda y que se ha vuelto la forma común
de pago en el país la novedad real de la
reconversión será que los venezolanos
van a tener por un tiempo dinero
efectivo en sus manos
y la creciente escasez de energía en
china estaba provocando apagones en los
hogares y obligando a las fábricas a
reducir la producción lo que amenaza con
afectar la economía del país y también
la economía global a las empresas que se
encuentran en el corazón industrial se
les ha dicho que limiten su consumo de
energía para así reducir la demanda
nuestro corresponsal en beijing adrián
foncillas con todos los detalles
no son raras las crisis energéticas en
china pero ninguna es comparable a la
actual que además llega en vísperas del
invierno cuando mayor es la demanda
energética 20 de las 31 provincias
chinas han adoptado restricciones
severas de electricidad lo que afecta no
sólo a la vida cotidiana de millones de
personas sino también a la actividad
empresarial muchas fábricas han tenido
que cerrar otras alumbran con velas o
han comprado generadores de gasóleo la
consecuencia lógica es que la actividad
manufacturera ha caído a sus niveles más
bajos desde la pandemia de coronavirus
la cámara de comercio de eeuu en
shanghai que agrupa a un millar de
compañías se lamentaba hoy que algunos
de esos cortes de luz se les habían
comunicado con apenas una o dos horas de
antelación lo que les ha provocado la
pérdida de pedidos o el deterioro de
materias primas la crisis explica que
goldman sachs había rebajado la
proyección de crecimiento anual desde el
82 por ciento al 78 % y es previsible
que los problemas de la fábrica global
también se extiendan al resto del mundo
especial cuando empieza la punta de
producción para satisfacer las demandas
de la campaña navideña y en australia
renunció la primera ministra de nueva
gales del sur gladys pérez y clanes
luego de que una comisión independiente
contra la corrupción abriera una
investigación para establecer si
defraudó la confianza pública entre 2012
y 2018 perejil ya no sólo renunció al
cargo sino también como miembro del
parlamento
de la gente de este estado necesita
certeza sobre quién es su líder durante
los tiempos difíciles de la pandemia no
podemos presidir cuánto tiempo le tomará
a la comisión contra la corrupción
completar esta investigación y mucho
menos entregar un informe en las
circunstancias donde me llamaron por
primera vez para declarar en una
audiencia pública hace casi 12 meses por
lo tanto me duele anunciar que no tengo
otra opción que renunciar a la oficina
de primer ministro
hitler a la lava emitida por el volcán a
cumbre vieja ubicado en la isla canaria
de la palma a cubre 709 hectáreas
incluido el terreno que le ha ganado al
mar el humo provocado y las cenizas
volcánica redujeron la visibilidad mil
cinco edificaciones han sido afectadas
de las cuales 870 han quedado totalmente
destruidas unas 6000 personas que fueron
evacuadas aún no regresan a sus hogares
pese a la llegada de la lava al mar las
autoridades confirmaron que el aire
sigue siendo seguro
y la activista climática sueca greta
tumbes se unió en milán a miles de
activistas en todo el mundo en una
marcha del movimiento viernes por el
futuro tras la cumbre climática
celebrada en esa ciudad italiana antes
de la cob 26 en glasgow los jóvenes
marcharon pacíficamente por las calles
de varias ciudades del planeta para
exigir a los legisladores que combinen
la retórica con la acción y que reúnan
los miles de millones de dólares
necesarios para que el mundo abandone
los combustibles fósiles hacia energías
más limpias durante un año que ha batido
récords de olas de calor inundaciones y
también de incendios
no
quiero tener un futuro este es nuestro
planeta y tenemos que protegerlo no
importa la edad que tengamos
necesitamos protegerlo para nosotros y
las generaciones venideras no hay conti
seguimos enviando mensajes pero creo que
ya no hay mucha necesidad de enviarlos
el planeta ya no nos está enviando la
ciencia lo dice todos enviamos mensajes
pero no debería ser necesario no servir
y de esta manera llegamos al final del
primer informativo del día en francés 24
dejemos a las 7 de la mañana a bogotá
quito lima con directo américa
[Música]